the movie begins with a train headed to
Turkey where a man can be seen walking
towards a bar inside the train
despite being a passenger the man is
denied service
a stranger comes to his Aid the man
seems to know this stranger as they talk
the man asks how one can steal their
daughter to torture the mother
alarmed at his words he gives an order
to his men a fight breaks out but soon
after the man overpowers them the scene
changes to a woman who is seen running
into a law firm she is reunited with her
daughter thanks to the man in the
morning a man named Robert McCall a Lyft
driver is seen engaging in small talk
with his passengers while keeping an eye
on the streets of Boston walking into
his compound he is welcomed by his
neighbor fatim
she grows vegetables in the compound
Roberto unlike his character is a very
simple man and can be seen living alone
in his apartment the scene switches from
Robert to a house in Belgium the husband
walking inside his house finds his wife
sitting at the table when three men
force him to sit down the man shot the
wife and then ordered the guy to shoot
himself making it look like it was done
by the husband
overpowered the man is shot the scene
changes to Robert entering a bookstore
the owner turns out to be the same woman
at the start of the movie and it seems
like he helped her out
he pays for his book after a small talk
with the woman and leaves
at work Robert receives a girl at a
hotel where a man instructs him to take
her home noting the girl's appearance he
returns back to the hotel after ensuring
her safety acting as if the card had
been declined he is welcomed into the
room realizing what had happened he
investigated the girl and informed them
about him getting her tested he allows
them to do the right thing by turning
themselves in
disregarding his offer he efficiently
fights all of them at home Robert is
welcomed by an old friend Susan she
updates him about work in her husband's
new books here it is found that Roberto
was an ex-cia officer who was now
pronounced dead for a while despite
Susan's persistent requests that he
return and work with her again he
refuses the next day on his way back
home he sees Fatima's Garden in the
walls vandalized by teenagers upset he
tries to fix it on his own miles a
resident living in the compound tells
him to leave it to the apartment to
which Robert comments that if no one
would do it and complain he would rather
do it impressed by him miles offers to
help him as an art student he had been
working odd jobs to pay bills so he
thought why not give this a shot the
scene switches to Susan in a meeting
with her co-worker Dave they seem to be
talking about the suicide Chase in
Brussels where her husband shows up to
check his outfit back to Robert he is
seen with Sam talking about his lost
painting and him finding his Sister
Magda Robert makes a note to check up on
that later that evening he meets up with
Susan and her husband she informs him
about flying to Belgium the next day
where Robert talks about the painting
and she tells him that she'll check it
out in Brussels Susan along with Dave
checks the crime scene it is evident
that it was a suicidal case and not
being sure of it they returned to the
hotel to investigate further agreeing to
meet up later Dave and Susan partways
making her way to the hotel room two
strangers attack her they Brawl for a
while but then the door is shut and the
scene changes accompanying miles with
his painting Robert asks miles about his
passion for art he replies that he'd
been painting for as long as he could
remember they are cut off when Robert
receives a call he's informed about
Susan's death he visits her house but
does not show up after everyone leaves
Brian Susan's husband hands Robert her
phone along with her other belongings
that night Robert tries to transfer the
files to his laptop meanwhile in
Brussels the men that had killed Susan
are killed in a gas explosion some men
can be seen leaving the site afterward
without having left his house in Days
Robert replays the videotapes he
received again and again trying to
figure out who was behind Susan's death
he notices that the two men had entered
before Dave and Susan figuring that they
already knew Susan in her position
clarified that her murder was planned
reviewing the autopsy report confirmed
his suspicion but knowing his hands were
tied he decides to visit Dave to ask for
help assuming that he had passed away in
an explosion Dave is shocked to see his
partner alive after these years he
agrees to help with the investigation
Robert informs him about the knife wound
and concludes that it was done by
someone trained returning home Robert
reenacts the entire crime scene in
Brussels according to the reports he was
trying to figure out what had happened
judging from his evidence Robert
believed that someone else was involved
Susan was about to crack the case which
is why she was killed he calls Dave to
check in with his guys
Dave agrees and hangs up meanwhile
Robert for several days had been
observing miles he knew that he had
given up on working on the painting he
decides to investigate the kid's
disappearance and notes the license of
the pickup car locating the car he
reaches an apartment complex reaching
the area he breaks in unarming the
guards at the door
Robert spots miles amongst the group of
gangsters he does manage to get miles
out of there but miles protests Robert
teaches him how the real world works
later miles visits Robert and asks him
for forgiveness and in return if he
could give his walls a Fresh coat
Robert agrees only if he would read a
book from his shelf whenever he did
later on his job a suspicious man enters
Robert's car he seems to be wanting to
get to the airport Robert's uneasiness
has proved when the man doesn't notice
the reroute alerted the man tries to
attack Robert with a knife at first but
then a gun Robert shoots the guy he goes
through the guy's phone and puts the car
on fire the scene then shifts to Dave
with his family early in the morning
a group of the same men the one in
Brussels are seen in a car across from
Dave's house while going through their
usual routine Dave seems to be checking
his phone anxiously
suddenly Dave's wife who went to check
the door does not reply but returns with
Robert surprised to see him Dave is
taken aback but covers it up
the kids are sent to get ready along
with his wife as Dave sits Robert down
Robert seems to have figured it out as
he catches Dave by calling him with the
Assassin's phone dropping the ACT Dave
admits that after Robert had died they
were going to shut the project down
the guys had to do something about their
situation so they took the wrong route
following orders of people who had paid
them for someone's life whether it is an
enemy or not Dave still believed
whatever they were doing was right but
Susan was going to figure everything out
so he had no choice but to end her life
Dave shows the rest of the team to him
they seem to be equally shocked to see
him alive Robert didn't care about what
they had become but his only concern was
them killing Susan without regret he
threatened to kill them they didn't
believe Robert as he warned all four of
them at night resneck and Ari two of
Dave's team members are seen breaking
into Susan's house but before their
arrival Robert visited Brian and ensured
his safety by taking him to a secure
location meanwhile in Robert's apartment
miles is giving his walls a new coat
when he receives a call from Robert he
asks miles about his location
informing him about being at Robert's
Place Robert asks miles to check his
surroundings miles tells Robert how
there was only a guy delivering pizza
knowing he instructs miles to his secret
hiding place behind the bookshelf just
as Dave and Kovac make their way inside
Robert's apartment miles has entered the
secret compartment there Robert
instructs him to be calm and stay quiet
they searched the place for Robert but
they don't find anyone both Dave and
Kovac almost catch miles through a
two-way mirror but are interrupted by
Robert calling them
he lets them know that he has eyes on
them because of cameras he hints to them
about where he was headed Dave figures
it out and they leave thinking that they
had left miles comes out of hiding and
is caught by the two Robert heads
towards his old house showing his police
badge as he gets stopped by local
sheriffs according to them a storm was
to hit the town and they had it
evacuated Dave along with the Airy Kovac
and Resnick team made their way to
Robert's Hometown they are loaded with
guns and armored when they arrive they
search the area being too windy Dave
goes to the higher ground and climbs a
watchtower having access to the area he
instructs Kovac to search a warehouse
making his way in he is tricked by
Robert and then later killed by an ax
resonic confirms kovac's death to Dave
Aries searching the area gets confused
by posters of Susan and then is blinded
by the sand due to the storm
taking advantage Robert strikes at him
killing him in an instant Robert then
checks his surroundings and shoots at
Dave with the help of a side mirror of a
car skillfully hiding from him by
shooting at an electricity pole he moves
towards his wife's Bakery
he sets a trap inside her Bakery as a
resident confirms RV's death to Dave he
makes his way inside the bakery it blows
up and Resnick is killed within seconds
having no other choice Dave threatens to
kill miles as he shoots at his car he
first shoots at the trunk the bullet
hits miles and he groans for the second
time when he's about to shoot the trunk
Robert shoots at the tire which causes
Dave's shot to be missed Furious he
stands to change positions when the wind
blows him to the other Corner which
causes Dave to hit his head taking
advantage of this Robert climbs the
tower and both Dave and Robert have a
fist fight
Robert ends up killing Dave and throwing
him into the sea miles is taken out of
the trunk and Robert tends to his wounds
the movie ends with the scene where
miles is finally taking his Art School
seriously and he paints Fatima's
memories up on the once vandalized walls
Sam the old man is reunited with his
long-lost Sister Magda and Robert is
seen back in his hometown